I was really excited when Richard asked
me to gave me this opportunity to give a
talk
because of the history that I have with
what used to be called the us-japan
Technology Management Center so but
talking about AI systems and
opportunities in Asia
I thought those are two concepts that
are really interesting when they come
together you probably all know there's a
ton of activity going on in AI in the
world and Asia and East Asia is a
particular hot spot so what I'll talk
about today will leave you all experts
hopefully in IOT technologies and
innovation and how it's using AI
technology and then what's going on in
Asia and where I think there are
opportunities now the word opportunity
is not only when you start a business
yourself but it's also when you can work
with other businesses that are in Asia
so I'll talk about those those two
concepts so let's get started today what
I'll talk about is from the
semiconductor industry point of view I
work at Intel as AI says Richard
introduced me I'm a director of
marketing in the IOT group and so from
the silicon perspective there are
various kinds of things going on in the
evolution of AI and I'll talk about
what's going on at the network edge or
at the edge and don't worry I know this
is an academic institution so I'll
define what I mean by these terms we'll
talk about the background I'll define
the network edge and we'll also look at
the trends and market dynamics and I'll
talk about what's going on and how we're
able to accelerate intelligent vision
technologies with opportunity with the
partnerships and various kinds of
business models that we have including
Asia and then of course I'll leave you
with some challenges that I think we
have in the industry that we'll have to
overcome but first I want to give a
little bit of an introduction to how I
got here
and it is kind of an interesting story
and there were a couple of revelations
that I thought would be kind of
entertaining I started out actually
before I even came to Stanford in this
program called the Eagle program when I
was an undergraduate just before my
junior year I found out that they were
taking engineers and scientists sending
them out to Terre Haute Indiana
where
we have the rose-hulman Institute of
Technology training them in Japanese I
thought wow that sounds pretty
interesting signed up went there learned
Japanese and that was the Eagle program
engineering Alliance for global
education I came to Stanford later on
after going to work in Japan and I took
some courses from the US Japan
Technology Management Center I actually
put my transcript up here and you'll see
they had Japanese manufacturing Japanese
business culture even an optoelectronics
seminar which were really cool this is
how I got to know Richard Asher from
these courses also from working as a TA
in his group so I benefited more than
once from working with the US Japan
Technology Management Center which is
the name of the u.s. Asia Technology
Management Center back in the 1990s and
I got to work on a research project with
a professor named Sam wood in the
Graduate School of Business this was a
very interesting project not only
because it paid my way through the
master's program but also because it was
about how Sony was able to take some
nascent technology and technology that
was invented in the United States at a
few different companies on the laser
diode and be able to mass manufacture
them for consumer electronics for CD
players and DVD players so it was a very
interesting study of what Sony was doing
with laser diodes and what I later found
out was all of that experience that I
had in the Eagle program and at the
us-japan Technology Management Center in
Stanford was because the Congress US
Congress had actually funded a program
to Train American universities to learn
about Japanese technology management and
both of those programs were part of the
list of the universities that were
benefiting from that funding so there
were students all over the US at these
universities in this program called the
Jade Japanese technology industry
management program I don't know the
exact name but the Jim T program and it
was really exciting to find out later on
Wow there was like a whole there was
some meaning to what was going on with
all of these programs and I was very
interested in learning about Asia and
technology man
so now we're gonna zoom forward to 2018
and we know that artificial intelligence
is a really hot topic that's what's
brought you here to this seminar so
here's some newspaper clippings random
clippings in South Korea in China and
Japan in India government's in East Asia
and Southeast Asia are investing a lot
of money and doing a lot that they can
to be able to do what they can to
introduce AI and take advantage of this
technology AI can do a lot and it can do
a lot for a lot of different companies
and it's a it's super hot topic as you
can see and it's booming now there's a
reason why it's booming and we're gonna
kind of peel back the layers and see
what why it is it's booming from the
semiconductor point of view so first I'm
gonna start taking you back to computer
vision and I'm going to talk about one
of the biggest applications of AI TV or
computer vision and what we're doing at
Intel to enable computer vision and AI
and systems at the edge so let's talk
about computer vision first and then
we'll talk about what the edge is so
computer vision you probably have heard
of this kind of technology you've
probably taken pictures with cameras
that can track people's faces and then
focus correctly on them or track your
pets and then focus correctly on them so
this is technology that's been around
for decades now I believe there was
actually research in the 1950s and 1960s
on being able to identify a face in a
photograph or to be able to identify the
landscape versus the sky versus trees
versus grass and all of these kinds of
fundamental classification problems or
image tracking or detection problems
this was an area called computer vision
which has been around for over 40 or 50
years so what has happened between 40 or
50 years ago and now well back then you
were writing these algorithms by hand
you would write them presumably on punch
cards and put them into the mainframe
computers like the ones shown there and
then the mainframe computer would crunch
out some data and you'd be able to write
these programs they would run I'll be it
fairly slowly and you would have
these you know kind of ways to to
identify photographs so now we zoom to
the present and we have AI and something
called deep learning which is a big area
of AI where you're actually training
algorithms that are mimicking the human
brain in the way the human brain
operates and you're training the
algorithms to recognize something or
recognize faces or recognize characters
and we also can run them in real time we
can also run them because of AI and
because of this deep learning technology
you can actually achieve very very high
accuracy so now an algorithm can achieve
99 or 100 almost close to 100% accuracy
with a very sophisticated AI algorithm
where in the past maybe you'll get 70%
accuracy maybe that was good enough or
on your camera 15 years ago tracking
faces maybe it didn't pick up
everybody's face but it picked up most
people's faces so that was good enough
but with deep learning
now with the larger your dataset the
larger of the amount of data that you
have to train your algorithm the more
accurate your algorithm can become and
also the more sophisticated the
algorithm is in other words the more
computations required by the algorithm
again the more accurate it can become
and it's also now miniaturized so you'll
see a picture of a chip that looks like
this and we'll get back to what this
chip does if you want to zoom in on the
chip chips this small can now do much
better than what those large computers
could do in the 1960s but it is still
amazing that hundreds of millions of
transistors on these chips can still do
computer vision so this can do roughly
four trillion operations per second of
16-bit floating-point calculations per
second and that can be used to do AI in
a miniature product like a small camera
or wearable or something like that so
let's move on to talk about what is the
edge this is now become a very hot topic
because now with the micro electronics
getting smaller lower power and faster
you can actually make devices like some
of the ones pictured here whether in a
retail store you'll have some cameras or
cameras doing security health and
medical devices that are doing medical
imaging so I picked some some
example edge devices that are doing
imaging but in this area you'll see
their their devices that are at the edge
of the network because they're just
terminated with some sensors and they
have a connection to the network to the
internet or the cloud in the back so
where the sensors are that's called the
edge those are edge devices now if you
move back one level to what where you
would connect those cameras let's say in
this university you have some security
cameras or some cameras that are
connected to some on-site appliances or
on-site network video recorders or
gateways it comes with various names but
this edge compute node is also
considered the edge because it's where
these cameras are being terminated and
it may also have some intelligence so
you can have an appliance that also has
to be fairly miniature fairly low plot
low power it's very different from the
data center that you find so where
you're doing a Google search online it's
actually going data is going to a very
large data center very high power very
super high performance but we're talking
about little appliances that are going
to be connecting maybe 40 cameras on
this side of campus maybe on the other
side of campus you have another 40
cameras they need to connect into these
local on-premise appliances so that's
what we call the edge the edge devices
and the edge servers or the edge compute
node and then on the other hand if I go
to the other side of this continuum you
have the network hub that these are
connected to when they're connected to
the cloud and then you have the cloud or
the data center in the back so you have
this continuum of the cloud which is
where you have a lot of performance
maybe no not so much regard to power
although you could argue we're trying to
make these data centers green so power
is still still a concern in the data
center but it's of extreme concern at
the edge because you might have a
wearable camera or you might have
security cameras that have to be very
small and have to fit within a dome they
can't so the thermal issue is the cost
issues power issues that's what we find
at the edge and that's why it's so
exciting is to be able to put the
performance required for AI all the way
into these edge devices and edge compute
nodes that's what the edges so to give
you an example of why the edge is so
important
so here's let's say a device kind of a
small simple diagram of a device at the
edge and then we have an edge compute
node that it's connected to and then
that's connected to the cloud so let's
just say it's you know in a hospital you
have cameras that are detecting where
patients are moving around or that or in
a factory where it's detecting whether
people are wearing the right safety
equipment and then those cameras are
connected to some edge server and then
the edge server is connected to the to
the network so the power required at the
edge device is very very low maybe a
couple of watts
then the POW if you have to transmit the
data to the edge server maybe it'll take
about five to 20 watts and then if you
have to move the data all the way and do
some computation or image processing to
detect things in the in the video in the
server then you're spending thousands of
watts so the more the the to the extent
that you're going into the cloud you're
actually spending quite a lot of power
that's an interesting concept so you
know what the edges and now you know how
the edge is so important because of
power concerns so now let's talk about
the opportunity for IOT in general and
then we'll start to talk about why Asia
is so important so there's a growing
opportunity for AI and from the silicon
point of view what we're going to look
at in this chart is the total available
market or the number of billions of
dollars available for silicon vendors
like my ourselves at Intel and all the
silicon vendors in doing what's called
inference and what and what's called
training so to train a neural network
you actually want to have the power of a
data center if you want to have as much
compute capability so that you can get
all of the images of faces you want into
your face detection algorithm and then
you can create your face detection
algorithm but then there's also the
deployment of the algorithm or what's
called inference we're actually running
it on a little device or running it in a
camera and when you run it then you want
to be able to run at very low power very
high performance so it ends up that over
the next five years what we're
predicting from some of the analysts
data that we have that the amount of
billions of dollars of silicon that's
going to be shipped in the edge for
deploy
these neural networks is actually
growing more than the data center both
inference you know because you're
talking let's say you're talking to your
little home appliance and it goes into
the network and interprets what you're
saying that's in the data center that's
data center inference also data center
training that the training technology
that people are using and both of those
combined it's still not growing as much
as the endpoint so the edge is actually
very very hot and this is why a lot of
companies are now trying to build very
low-power very high performance devices
for doing AI because it's growing at a
twenty five to thirty five percent
annual growth rate over the next five
years so there's another dynamic to get
you all up to speed with what's going on
in the AI at the edge which is that to
the extent that the chip technology is
doing more and more the applications are
now able to do more and are getting more
accurate and more interesting and
they're more interesting use cases in
all kinds of different areas we'll go
into that but then in order to then
they're requiring more and then pushing
back on the chip industry to be able to
supply even higher performance at even
low power with even lower latency with
even lower cost and so there's this
virtuous cycle of the chip companies
like my own developing better better
silicon that's being that's enabling
more interesting uses in various
applications and then it's just kind of
circular so there's a lot of exciting
development going on and almost a global
race to see who can perform you know the
best algorithms that are the most
accurate and if you go to any of these
academic conferences for example cvpr in
the summer or the nips conference in the
fall and December a lot of academic
papers coming out showing that you know
my network is 1% better than the last
guys and someone else who will then do a
half a percent better than the last one
and so there's you know inching toward
neural networks and deep learning
algorithms in AI that can achieve more
and more accuracy and in some cases
requiring less and less computation so
I've been talking about what are these
use cases so this is something also that
applies
where in the world but the interesting
thing about some of these use cases are
some of them are hotter in different
regions of the world so let's just take
city state and federal so federal public
safety traffic congestion there are
different ways in which you know raising
the IQ of the city means that you have
cameras that can detect traffic
congestion and and other kinds of things
or delivering tickets to cars that are
speeding through the stoplights there's
also in finance and banking having ATMs
that can recognize the what you'd like
to do and be able to give you services
better and more efficiently making the
customer experience even better one
interesting example in finance going
into a bank and you know there's like
20,000 or 30,000 pick any bank and
they'll have a lot of different outlets
all over the country but they may only
have mortgage experts you know in
certain parts and so if the mortgage
experts not there well you have to call
but they'll have you know maybe kiosks
you can approach the kiosk get the
mortgage expert talk face-to-face even
if they're not on site with you so
that's one example of using technology
in in finance and banking detecting your
gender and wait time and kind of using
that data and doing some analytics if
you're in line in queuing up for for a
kiosk now industrial and machine vision
is a very big area in countries like
Japan they're companies that do factory
automation robotics elsewhere in Asia
companies that are using technology to
inspect a lot faster you know if a human
being is picking up a device and looking
and trying to inspect it could be a lot
better if you've trained an algorithm to
to understand based on millions and
millions of images what the defects are
so we'll talk about the industrial and a
little bit more depth on the next slide
also concealed gaming transportation of
course cars are becoming automated
having autonomous vehicles and also
being able to detect not just outside
the car for safety purposes but inside
the car if you've left your cell phone
behind wouldn't it be great to be able
to get notified and
that you would left something behind in
a taxi or something like that or an uber
home and retail surveillance being able
to have better cameras in the home or
even a thermostat that's smart so that
when you're cooking in the kitchen it'll
know to adjust because it knows you're
in the kitchen cooking or you're
traveling to the living room and so
you're away from the kitchen so now
it'll just it's like having automatic
home comfort improved through the use of
visual analytics that's another really
key area for AI systems and robotics and
drones so let's deep dive into two of
those examples and then I'll tell you a
little bit more about what my company is
doing and how we're using our
relationships in Asia I just kind of
wanted to give you a little bit of the
background in this area so let's look at
a smart factory so this is an example of
again looking at the things at the edge
the devices at the edge and also the
compute node and all the way into the
cloud what you might see in the factory
of the future whether it's a couple of
years in the future or a number of years
in the future a warehouse that could be
using robots to move equipment around of
course it uses vision to control the
robots you might also do sorting based
on cameras that can detect and what
items need to be placed where and how
they need to be sorted so there's a lot
of computer vision and using these AI
algorithms to be able to do very
accurate kinds of you know warehouse
sorting and various carrying of items
I'm also detection of safety gear this
was a demonstration that was performed
by one of our partner companies is
detecting that you've worn the helmet
detecting that you've worn the safety
gear you can imagine you're avoiding
accidents if you can tell which
employees in the factory are not wearing
the safety gear and doing that kind of
semi autonomously on via cameras and
then of course the data can be viewed
maybe by PCs and other people in other
areas the data can go into the cloud and
be controlled from there so let's look
at an actual real example of how a
factory is using Intel products that's
what we know so if you look at these
various different blocks I'm going to
start
the right at the edge where we have an
industrial PC so it's very typical in a
factory that you want to have a very
sturdy PC that's going to be running
some kind of management of cameras it'll
also be have a very powerful CPU so the
cameras can have in the case in the
picture here we're showing Intel Nvidia
s-- the chip that I showed you before is
the brand Intel Nvidia so this does four
trillion operations per second of
artificial intelligence on the camera
input coming in and then it's streaming
that kind of metadata into the PC and
then it's streaming into an edge server
so the edge server then takes that data
and it can do higher level things that
can detect okay we found a problem on
the manufacturing line over there and we
found a problem over there and so it can
kind of make higher-level decisions
based on the stream metadata about where
these cameras are or what kind of
product defects you're finding or those
things defect detection is actually the
biggest reason why I think technology AI
technologies being used in factories
because it'll save a lot of time it
makes the factory more efficient and in
fact I heard that installing robots and
factories actually produces more jobs
because it's more electronics to
maintain more robots to maintain there
might have been one person manually
looking for defects before but now you
have a robot that can grab the items of
a from the manufacturing line make sure
all of them all the size of the product
errors are aimed at a camera and then
those images are rapidly being analyzed
by AI algorithms ciller for defects now
the interesting thing that is then
it can be looked at using these
dashboards and you can review based
across multiple factories through the
dashboard you know what the status is
and where you're finding product defects
and such so this is an actual use case
and one of the interesting things about
why you need to do training of AI
algorithms even in these edge servers is
that you might find a new defect you
didn't know before and then you want to
be able to transmit that information
update your AI algorithm to include that
defect have a new algorithm that's
trained and then spread that to the
other factories if you have a number of
them that are all building the same
similar products so even at the edge you
sometimes have to do a training of AI
technology so let's look at another
example
smart stores this is really exciting
because you can imagine when you walk
into a supermarket and you take
something off the shelf and it's the
last one
it usually takes them some time to
figure out that that was the last
product inventory control inventory
management it's very important to do
this very accurately it's sometimes
upsetting to me when I go to a store to
find something and there's nothing there
and then they go oh but we have one at
that other site 20 miles away and then
you drive 20 miles but they don't have
it either so this happened to you many
times I'm sure but it won't happen when
you have AI technology powering cameras
that can actually be used to detect when
items are pulled off the shelf or
looking at inventory like actually on
the shelf and then using the metadata in
the edge servers to look at the store
analytics and inventory management and
there's also another interesting dynamic
is that when you're walking into the
store and you pick something off the
shelf and look at it and you realize
it's a bit expensive and put it back or
you look at the label and we look at the
ingredients and then put it back so that
data can actually be accumulated and
then that manufacturer could be notified
that of you know a hundred people on
average who are picking up their product
50 people put it back on the shelf so by
tracking people throughout the store and
tracking what items are being lifted by
the person those kinds of gestures can
be recognized by behavioral analytics
powered by these kinds of AI algorithms
and it's interesting also I've met
companies doing eye tracking
that in the store the person's gaze and
which products they're looking at on
which shelves can also be tracked and
that's very valuable marketing
information so the supermarket of the
future with this kind of analytics can
be hone in on which products are the
most popular and put them and stock them
up and it'll probably make the consumer
experience a lot better and it also
gives them a lot more quick ability to
know the the stores themselves the
ability to track their inventory so
that's another example of AI being used
at the edge but again the technology
needs to be super fast it needs to be
very miniature it needs to be cost
effective it also needs to be very
low-power so this is all a very big
challenge for the industry so now we're
going to go into shift into what is
Intel doing in this area and how are we
finding opportunities in Asia
and how does this impact our business so
I mentioned before the mova Dias silicon
which here I'll show it once more we're
very proud of these processors that are
very small somewhat inexpensive and can
perform trillions of operations per
second so this is used to connect
cameras and do the imaging of the camera
it can also do computer vision
algorithms various standard traditional
algorithms as well as the deep learning
inference so that you can perform AI
algorithms in these kinds of edge
products but it's not just a technical
problem so you'd think that oh if we
build the right chips and if we can make
the chips high-performance low power low
latency low cost then should in our
business just grow and grow and grow
well it's also important that you have
to scale the technology to get out to
the developers who want the technology
and how do we scale to developers
worldwide that's where the opportunities
in Asia really come in and I'll explain
in a little bit more detail
so one of the issues about the IOT
business is that when we sell these
chips we're not selling it to the end
customer so let's say the end customer
is a fast food chain and they want to be
able to put cameras into their store to
be able to identify how fast customers
are coming in how fast they're ordering
french fries and they want to be able to
serve those french fries fresh and not
you
as much oil and limit how much resources
are going to waste by tracking people
moving into their store that's a
possibly a real use case will they buy
these chips directly from Intel possibly
not of course they want to be able to
call up and installer just like you
would install a home security system the
system integrator is then installing the
equipment now where does the system
integrator get their equipment they're
buying the equipment from the appliance
makers who are maybe building the
appliances or building the cameras
building devices and then those camera
makers are actually buying the silicon
from Intel or they're possibly even
buying PCB boards that are made with the
Intel chips so you see there's a number
of companies in the chain and that's why
there's a channel of there's a whole big
complex channel of customers and custard
those customers customers and those
customers customers before you get to
the end customer so it's very
sophisticated business so what I'm
showing up here now is how we make a
business out of these chips in an
industry where you have to sell to a
device maker the device maker or the
appliance makers then selling to a
system integrator and then they're
getting to the end customers the end
customers may build the security system
on a ship or they might build the ship
tracking system that's on the dock or
but you know we don't talk directly to
the end customer of course we do talk to
them and learn a lot from them but we're
selling through this channel so one of
the ways to sell through the channel is
to work with partners on building boards
so we can build boards that have one
chip or even better than one is to and
even better than two is eight and so we
have these kinds of hardware partners
that are manufacturing these boards that
are not manufactured by my company but
they're manufactured to be able to
supply to the camera makers or supply to
the appliance makers so this is an
example of one of those boards and we've
just launched this a few weeks ago it's
called the vision accelerator designs
Intel vision accelerator designs an
exciting thing about it is that we've
actually worked with a lot of these
manufacturers that are in Asia that are
experts at building boards and these
boards are not easy to build you might
think Oh PCB board breadboard I've done
that before
I've taken my graduate course and
Stanford EE I know how to do that but
the chip is this sophisticated and it
takes and each of the pins on the chip
are 0.4 millimeters apart it's actually
quite difficult to build one of these
boards and to be able to solder them on
you can't solder them on by hand so
there's a lot of technology used in
building the boards and also building
them in a way that's very standard so
standard mini pcie or standard m2 so we
rely on these partners to be able to
build these boards to be able to then
get out into the industry one example of
a partner is kaga electronics we
announced earlier this year a
relationship that intel has with kaga
electronics this is their webpage for
those of you who speak Japanese you can
tell that they're talking about
accelerating accelerator boards using
deep learning and that's what this is so
they have their own sales they have
their own distribution they have their
own business and we are their
quarterback behind them shipping them
the silicon working with them on
understanding how to build the silicon
correctly from our reference designs and
then they can go off and do their own
business so if you're a big company in
Japan and you're looking to build some
kind of machine vision camera for
industrial purposes or a factory
automation camera you can go contact
kaga electronics and they can work with
you on that
another example partner based in Taiwan
I'll point out is a on allens an
interesting company they do a lot of
different kinds of boards they do a lot
of different kinds of form factor cards
for different kinds of businesses and
they're out promoting the same kinds of
products and they make little dev kits
you can see you can plug this one
directly into the Internet to your
Ethernet so there another interesting
partner and we have a number of other
partners next comm who's been building
robotics
so next comm builds robots that are
connected to the PCs that have these
edge server cards in them other
companies like adlink III and advantech
so for Intel the business can't really
grow when we're trying to directly ship
chips to customers directly because then
there's just they can't use them but
when you have partners
these companies that are experts in
building boards experts and then
customizing them for certain industries
some of them have their own focus areas
like machine vision robotics retail etc
so then it makes the business actually
work so in a in a field like IOT where
it is a channel business you require
partners like these and they're really
great to work with and we also announced
recently a larger partner program so
just those partners are on this slide
but you also have another a slew of
different partners because some some of
these companies have to do software and
then they're plugged into the boxes that
have these cards in them some of the
companies are doing industry specific
application software or hardware and
rely on those partners that are building
the boards and then we have other new
partners that are coming to work with us
so we have a whole large ecosystem and
if you were to look at where all of
these companies are a large number of
them are actually coming from Asia from
China from Taiwan from Korea from Japan
there are many partners also in the US
and Europe as well we've also have you
know so partners of different kinds
either in different segments one example
gorilla does video management software
for security and surveillance so we have
a large partner program and we're
constantly working with these partners
and we have large partner teams that
manage those partners and part of the
success of our IOT business at Intel is
directly because we have this partner
ecosystem and we act like the
quarterback because it's our silicon
which powers what's going on but it
would never be successful without the
partners especially the ones in Asia now
there are some Tier one companies that
we work with and I wanted to bring out
one example Alibaba
now who has not heard of Alibaba it's a
large company that they're transforming
the way people are doing computing and
Intel has also announced publicly that
back in September just
a couple of one month ago that we're
working with them on some basic
platforms for edge computing so it's not
just us taking our silicon and shipping
it out for whatever the customers want
to do we're actually creating something
called the joint edge computing platform
so it's really exciting and we plan to
showcase that at the Tokyo Olympics in
2020 so they're our Tier one companies
that will work with very closely some of
them in China like Alibaba and other
parts of Asia so I think one thing I was
going to say in the very beginning when
I lived in Japan over years ago
I realized there's a there's a way of
thinking a something cultural there's a
very methodical way of thinking and I
keep thinking that people are very
methodical in Asia and I think one of
the reasons which many of our ecosystem
partners are so successful in areas of
high tech that are on the bleeding edge
like AI systems at the network edge is
because of the way of thinking being
very methodical coming up with systems
that actually work trying and trying
again and I think in other parts of the
world we also have many many people and
a lot of innovation so I'm not pointing
out that Asia is somehow peculiar or
different than the rest of the world but
there's a methodical way of thinking
that I think goes hand-in-hand with the
culture that I think is the fuel tour in
some of these kinds of partnerships fuel
in some of these areas so I'd like to
leave you with some ideas about the
challenges that we have in the
semiconductor field I think many
different semiconductor companies are
going to find these kinds of challenges
that we have to overcome to make more of
these edge devices and edge products
possible so if you look at so I created
this little graph it's not it wouldn't
pass maybe an academic test but in
general what we're seeing today is
neural networks like this neural network
called resin at 50 and if you send
images one at a time
which in the what we say is batch size
equals one so one at a time you're
sending an image you know it makes up a
video stream through this
neural network and your si trying to do
some detection or some classification
how many inferences it can do per second
so as how fast this neural network can
perform on a given platform what we're
finding today is maybe 20 30 40 50
frames per second so you can run the
video at 50 frames per second and for
every frame it will capture and detect
what you wanted to detect or however you
train the neural network on whatever
training data set that you have so that
we're down here in terms of performance
but every year over the next five years
I see it's going to grow exponentially
so to a hundred frames per second to a
thousand frames per second and we're
going to require maybe three orders of
magnitude more performance at the same
power of five to ten watts
moving down the road so every year what
we've seen is now people are running
more sophisticated neural networks or
they're running multiple sophisticated
neural networks
I mean imagine in a device you want to
detect something and then you want to
classify it you detect the object and
then you want to classify is it a dog or
a cat so that's two neural networks you
have to run and the speed and everything
else factored in I think there's a
really rapid climb in terms of the
required performance that you need yet
can we spend more power on it no because
it's going to be in a miniature edge
product or it's going to be in some kind
of product where the thermal design is
such that it has to be very miniature so
what are the kinds of steps that we're
taking in the semiconductor area to try
to combat this kind of issue of the
requirements in new kinds of use cases
and let me just say I see a trend in
Asia where there are very interesting
use cases in retail or in industrial
manufacturing and I I would even say
that in China I think there's a very
aggressive breakneck speed at which
companies are trying to implement these
in actual factories or in actual retail
environments so this may even be a
conservative look at what the
semiconductor industry has to do to be
able to support those applications but
anyway some of the techniques that we're
doing are we're taking neural networks
that have to perform at like 16 bit
resolution and we're having to compress
them down to compute them at 8-bit
resolution or 4-bit resolution or one
bit resolution and as you require fewer
bits you can do more computations but
then it's also not as quite not quite as
accurate so you lose some accuracy but
you have to do very special techniques
to try to counterbalance that so that's
one technique also taking these neural
networks where some of the neurons and
some of the data coming through might be
zeros in which case you might be
multiplying zero times zero why would
you ever do that so you can take
advantage of the fact that some of these
multiplications you're doing are sparse
and so you can do various techniques to
take advantage and get even more
computation capability or you have
efficient memory so that's something
that we've been working on a lot at
Intel is how to get data in and out of
the chips and how to get the data flow
to require less power and be much more
efficient many of you may not know this
but the processing of the data versus
the movement of the data in many cases
the movement takes up much more power
than the processing itself so don't be
fooled by companies that say well our
processor is capable of this much at
this power well but what about moving
the data in and out of the chip if it's
inefficient then that could cause a lot
of power so that's another area also
companies are coming up you'll read
articles about new startups that are
coming up with accelerators and
different kinds of engines for neural
networks neural computing our chip has
something called the neural compute
engine that puts into hardware
capability that can do it very very
efficiently but it's not programmable so
then there's a trade-off between program
ability and hardwired functions and then
also compilers and tools so there's a
lot of things that the that the
technology companies like Intel have to
do but then we take advantage of working
with companies that are very innovative
and also working with companies in Asia
that help us fan out in terms of our
partnerships and then we can be
successful so to conclude the talk
before we have some questions and
answers I'll just say the future is kind
of unknown but you know a lot of
companies are doing really interesting
things and it
a lot to be closely watching what's
going on in East Asia Southeast Asia
countries like China Japan Taiwan Korea
are working very very hard in AI systems
and I'm really proud that companies like
Intel are there to help support their
work as well as in the rest of the world
but you know with the partnerships I
think there's a lot of really
interesting things that you'll see
coming from our company so that's it for
today thank you very much
[Applause]